oh yeah
um
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
um
[Music]
at least
yeah i
um
[Music]
[Music]
daily editor's choice because i wanted
to get he's going to talk good luck
i don't know
[Music]
um
no but like if you check with them
whatever
not yet i'm gonna try to get a lot done
so um
look at that smelly
oh
oh
oh
because you can't
uh
utilities
oh
um
[Music]
it's a common tool
anymore
[Music]
sure
so you can't go in february they're
doing staff in february
yeah i got something on 2 4.
that's okay
interest in here so i'll make room for
him again in the gear closet
because who knows maybe spring you'll
want to shoot some more stuff i know
it's a big box
my father-in-law was going to throw that
box out because that used to be his dive
box
then i'm like wait a minute what size is
that box and i measured him like
perfect because it's a stupid pelican
but for that i mean literally he
couldn't have been born
[Music]
um
i'm doing it because i have to do
something today
um
[Music]
two minutes
they want you to actually research the
news what's going on and find a way to
tell a story instead of just going to
take a picture snow on a plow in the
field
oh my god
no no no nothing i know
okay
such a show
oh
[Music]
off you know
uh
okay um
i thought the flights were safe kevin
maybe the air in there so much
food things
what i want to know about is uh world
cup next year
guitar what time of year is it supposed
to take place
well next year next year
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
air conditioning
um
[Music]
right that's always cool with this
yeah well it's not actually it could be
anything
you could say right what do you have it
said
i decided
right
oh
hey
good morning so here we are
the hail hoop with the house or
so with the eagles early in the morning
here not that early but
in the inclement weather and speaking of
inclement weather
hearts and prayers go out to the people
of texas for what they are suffering in
their
situation there in terms of lack of
water
lack of energy like uh i had my daughter
have a daughter
in houston so i know firsthand what her
concerns are but
her concerns are minor compared to
people
i need people truly in need to lose
water and service
for my family is one thing but for
people
who don't have so many options uh
it's just heartbreaking i would hope
that
the public policy of the state would
recognize
uh the needs that are there we have in
our coveted bill 50 billion dollars
for fema president has responded to the
call for disaster assistance he did that
on sunday morning
now fema will pray take a measure of
what the needs
are we want to be sure to have the funds
there are there other needs that my
colleagues
of uh from texas have told us about the
needs that relate
to nutrition again the
the fact that some people were hopeful
of getting their vaccine
their vaccination their vaccine shot or
not able to do it
and it is so they want
immediate assistance from fema uh
to replenish texas water supply and help
texas
uh obtain safe and drinkable water uh
immediate assistance from fema to
respond to texas for emergency personal
assistance through direct payments
and home repair assistance meet
assistance from fema first
and sba to aid small businesses
requests for implement disaster
supplemental nutrition
snap food food
uh and to allow temporary responsibility
in snap eligibility
authorization of emergency
appropriations for low income
for la heap la heap would enter into
this
that lie heap for those of you who are
new low income home energy assistance
program
then it goes on and on
so in any event uh assistance in
delivery storage and
of the coveted vaccination to name a few
of the uh immediate needs that people
have
everybody has their personal experience
my daughter's
home has no water pipes are breaking all
over because of the cold
again they can handle it but a lot of
people
can't so it's a
the question of needing water and food
and energy
and vaccines and the rest uh we really
have to be
on top of that and hope that there would
be some
preparation for the future this was in
many ways
uh predictable uh uh in
in a long range of weatherizing the
uh infrastructure of energy in the state
uh that's a longer range of
discussion but in the media to have
given people
an earlier alert as to what their
concerns would be i believe that the
energy and commerce committee
will be taking up some form
of when i say investigation i mean
a look into it to see how uh things
could have turned out better and will
turn out better in the future
at the same time i'm so proud of the
work of our members the chairs of the
committees of jurisdiction the members
the staff i feel as if we've worked the
staff
24 7 for a number of weeks now
to make sure that we stay on schedule
with the american rescue plan
the biden plan it is uh
as you know a couple of weeks ago we
passed the budget
bill so for reconciliation to protect
the 51 vote privilege uh then last week
we
wrote up the bill within that framework
within different committees of
jurisdiction honoring their
amounts and then that now has gone to
the budget committee
which will consolidate all of that make
sure
that it is again in keeping with what
reconciliation uh allows
and that will then go to this rules
committee for us to
vote on sometime at the end of next week
is my hope
however at the same time that is there's
communication with the senate as to what
the byrd rule will allow in the bills as
we go forward so
that's kind of where we are on that and
people have worked so hard
and so intensely because as i said to
the members
when we have been briefing them the last
few days we've had
under leadership of our chair uh hakeem
jeffries and
pete aguilar the vice chair every day
we've had
the chairs present what is in the bills
not for uh suggestions of amendment
but for notification of this is what
the overall reconciliation
enables us to do and this is how we are
uh going forward so i'm very very proud
of their work today is a busy day i know
with the snow and sleet and the rest but
today we have the u.s citizenship
act which will be introduced uh linda
sanchez the lead in the house bob
menendez the chair
of the foreign affairs committee in the
senate
equality act this is something it's very
exciting for us equality act we passed
it of course before
uh and hopefully now it will be passed
into law in the senate because it will
have
bipartisan it will have bipartisan
support
the business community is
supportive because they want the very
best
in their workforce and in order for that
to happen we have to remove
discrimination
in all aspects of our society and our
economy so
i thank david sicilini for his
leadership in passing the senator
merkley
in the senate and then we're very
pleased that the strong bipartisan
support we have for the congressional
gold medal
to honor our capitol police naming a few
of them
uh for their courage and their valor
and for saving our lives without them
who knows how
bad this could have gone but uh
i'm very pleased that we have very very
strong bipartisan support
and with the leadership mr mccarthy and
mr scalise as well as the leadership on
the
democratic side as well you saw the
senate
announce their support for this the
night
on saturday night and then we will
come together and pass this legislation
and then
uh we're working on the uh the
commission of the january 6 commission
what's happening there in that timetable
is the following of
everybody was saying we need to have a
commission and this or that
i was very much a part of writing the
commission in 2000
in the of the the 911 commission
you've you've heard me go through that
before
and so we heard almost immediately or
sometime last week from the chairs of
that
of that commission uh governor cain of
new jersey and
and our chief former chairman in the
house
lee hamilton and they had sent us all a
letter
the leadership the president the vice
president leadership house and senate
saying this is what we think
should be in the legislation it wasn't
um too far from what everybody thought
what let's
what are the causes of what happened 911
what is the truth there
how uh what does the security security
security
uh um look at how the security
uh can protect us better preparedness
can protect us
in the future and how did that go wrong
uh is what they had in the letter they
also had a provision that they wanted
which is
to uh strengthen congress the
view that the public has of congress and
we'll see how we can deal with that
but by and large most of what they
suggested
very much mirrors what we had in the
bill
that we wrote in 2011 at the time a
foot for the not 2011 the 911
uh commission so uh that legislation
plus their report plus their letter is
pretty much the basis
uh for what we have as soon as we
came to terms with that in the last few
days we sent it to the republicans to
see
what um suggestions they may have
because
for this to work it really has to be
strongly
bipartisan so we'll hear back from them
on that
and uh uh i'm excited about that but
when we did it in 2000 and 2001
the families of 911 really weighed in on
it
there's really strong support in the
country for us to have
seek the truth find the truth but also
understand how we have to protect the
american people
from what might be out there in terms of
domestic terrorism and the rest any
questions
yes ma'am i wanted to ask you on january
13th a number of year democrat
colleagues
sent a letter to the sergeant-at-arms
and u.s capitol police
regarding potential reconnaissance force
by gop
members that happened on january 5th
prior to january 6th
i wanted to know if these have been
confirmed and that there's an update on
that specific
aspect of the investigation no uh
anything like that would remain
between the member who has the members
who
know of such uh actions and uh
i don't know what the i don't know i do
not know
perhaps i will find out at some point
but i do not know
what numbers they are referencing i
think that's between them
and whoever would be investigating it
have you seen that letter
from january 13 yeah the letter that was
signed by members yeah that was a matter
of public in the public domain yes sir
do you anticipate that this commission
will have subpoena power i mean what
kind of power do you think the
commission wants
well you can't have you have to have
subpoena power yes
yes yes ma'am you think that teachers
need to be vaccinated
before heading back into the classroom
well it depends on
them i think the degree of the incidence
of covid
in their area i think i think suture
should be vaccinated i don't know that
they must be vaccinated before going in
we're very proud of what's in our bill
when it comes to education
because this is where we're saying that
we want the children to
be in school again i told you about my
daughter
not having water in houston i have a
granddaughter in public school
uh in um san francisco so i see the
the need for that to happen again in her
case she has
all the technology and the assistance at
home and some children do not
so we want as many kids to be back in
school as possible for that to happen
it takes some money it takes some money
because you have to have
spatial distancing which means you need
more space therefore you need more
teachers therefore you need more buses
for kids to be spaced to come to school
you need better ventilation 40 percent
of the school public schools in the
country have
a substandard ventilation
uh in the class and that is very
important
so for all of those reasons we're very
pleased with what is in the legislation
and more of those and more the uh
we i think that uh i want everybody to
be vaccinated and i certainly want our
teachers to be
uh but it depending on what the
situation is in their
area it may or may not be necessary now
the important point to make on this is
where there is a high incidence of um
of of covid most of those schools are
virtual or hybrid
anyway they're not uh actual
they're not actual and the vaccination
might not make it
actual anyway so again there has to be a
judgment made
from the community as to how they go
forward
uh i would again we want the vaccine to
be there for everyone
i think it's it's having an impact we're
very
proud of the scientists work 24 7 to get
uh right now covet um
pfizer and and modern
uh what they have put forth and now
others on the horizon
and that will make it more available but
i don't think that it's a
yes or no question i think it depends on
the
incidents of covet in the region and if
in fact
those classes will even be actual one of
the fights we had
and i used the word fight that we had
with the trump administration last year
was that they wanted the funds
in the bill only to go to schools that
were actually
open and how could you do that
you were depriving so many schools who
are lacking
in ventilation and more space and more
opportunity to hire
teachers therefore you were
disadvantaging
the most disadvantaged schools in the
country and that just couldn't be
and this this uh legislation is very
smart in what it does and if you want me
to i'll read you all the things that it
does do
uh to open schools and again yes we want
everyone vaccinated
is it a pre-requisite well it just
depends
on the region yes ma'am speaker speaker
in the funding
republicans say that just a fraction of
the education funding in the kobe bill
is just
allocated for this year and much of it
over the next 10 years
so how do you square that with the need
to open schools with the funding if some
of
so much of it was down the road i uh
don't place too much
weight on what the republicans say even
though it seems to be a value to you to
use as a question
but the fact is is that this is the
money that is needed
this is the money that is needed the
hundred and thirty billion dollars in k
through
will help provide immediate relief
to school so they can safely reopen for
in-person instruction
and address the difficult uh multi-year
challenges making up lost time
in the classroom this learning loss
is is heartbreaking for children and of
course
we're hoping that summer school and the
rest can make up
for some of it the dewy to which
in-person learning takes place in a
state is a
local decision uh not a federal one but
the federal
arm can and will make recommendations
and provide
resources it's about resources and look
to look
and that's what we plan to do in this
legislation
uh the committee on education and labor
advanced a major portion
of the president's covet proposal last
week
for education 130 for k-12
and then additional money for higher
education now let me also say
that education is largely funded more
than 90 percent
by state and local entities
and so that's why the state and local
peace in here
is very very important as well so it's
in fact
and i think it is a fact that we all
want children back in school
there has to be a recognition that it's
going to take resources to do so
and to be spent as soon as it possibly
can
be as the as i mentioned
immediately immediate relief to school
so they can safely reopen with in-person
uh education yes ma'am speaker with
respect to immigration do you think this
new package that's being unveiled today
excuse me i'm so sorry i'm i'm sorry
with respect to the
immigration hacking oh yeah today do you
envision that having to be pushed
through
the reconciliation process
not necessarily no of the uh
the today they will introduce the
legislation
what we as i mentioned to you earlier
what we did
but we informed members of this is
the design it is frozen
and it is complies with the
reconciliation i don't
see anything of that size now there are
people who are
advocating for that and the question is
would that uh would that meet the uh
bird rule and those other kinds of
things and if it would that would be
wonderful
because then we wouldn't need the 60
votes but
but i salute the president for putting
forth
the legislation that he did there are
others who want to do piecemeal
and that may be a good approach too
that's up to the congress to decide
but i was thinking this morning in
anticipation of their announcement of
the citizenship act
that a few years ago a couple years ago
i guess it must be longer than that now
when trump was a new president
oh did i say his name uh that that
um when they did the ban the muslim ban
we had a hearing a rump hearing because
we were not the majority
and we couldn't do that and at that
hearing i think it's really important to
note two things
that relate to this introduction today
one was uh that when we had economists
speak
they said we said what is the most
important thing we can do
to um grow the economy
comprehensive immigration reform and
when the
evangelicals spoke and that was not just
at that hearing but at other hearings
that we had comprehensive immigration
reform will grow
our gdp that's very important and when
we had at the
the particular hearing i was mentioning
the muslim ban hearing
the evangelicals spoke the
representative for the
american evangelical association
whatever the title is
about assad refugees
refugees which are in this bill he said
the refugee resettlement program of the
united states of america
is the crown jewel
is the crown jewel of our
humanitarianism
the refugee resettlement program that
was
the evangelical community speaking up
because they have been leaders
in that regard both of those are covered
comprehensive immigration reform and
resettlement
of refugees in a humanitarian way
the crown jewel of american
humanitarianism
so this is a values-based but also
economically beneficial
and as i have always said immigrants
coming to our country
with newcomers coming with their hopes
and dreams and aspirations
with their optimism and determination to
make the future better for their
families
well those are american traits and when
they come here with those
values they make america more american
so i'm
very excited about uh the uh now how it
happens
through the legislative process remains
to be seen
uh but it it is a priority and we will
be
working on it yes ma'am
[Music]
president joe biden during a town hall
this week and said that the us should
speak up
for human rights in china i know you've
been very vocal about it and he said
that there will be repercussions for
china
uh what actions would you like to see
from president biden
to change china's human rights facts
yeah
well thank you for that question yes
i've been working on human rights in
china for over
30 years since tiananmen square and it
is uh
it's really important for the world the
world to know
that human rights are part of our value
system
uh as we engage in the world we
about our national security it's about
our
our military and our strength it's about
our economy
and how we interact and it's about our
values
and and we cannot sacrifice one
uh for the other how what form that
takes i would hope
that uh that it would change some
behavior
in china visa the hong kong uh
tibet uh wigars
weak ours it's really interesting to me
that it took us a hundred years to have
the armenian genocide declared a
genocide and they've already declared
the what was happening to the wigars
a genocide so i think that that's a a
very strong
statement it's also a strong statement
for the people who are
i have a relationship over time with so
many
of those who have been
arrested for years in uh
prison labor camps and all the rest of
that i'm so proud of that
uh and basically what they tell us the
coolest form
of torture for them is when the uh
chinese authorities come in and say
nobody even knows you're here
they don't even remember why you're here
and the rest so
that's why it's important for us to
speak out so that those people know
that they are not forgotten even by name
in many cases we have named them and by
the way
in a very bipartisan way i've worked for
over 30 years with my republican
counterparts across the aisle
one of them who is still here chris
smith and i have worked on these issues
for years but frank wolf before and oh
just a whole long list
of um of republican members who have
been
excellent on human rights throughout the
world
you just name china but and throughout
the world
they've taken risks they've gone to
prison
labor camps to collect evidence so that
we could make
our case here but i salute the
administration for honoring our values
how we go about it it's just in weighing
the equities
the chinese know and those who are
arrested suppressed whatever know that
they are not forgotten thank you all
very much be careful on your way
home uh don't go too late because you
don't want to be traveling in the dark
with all of this do you have any other
grandmotherly advice that you would like
me to give to you
but i really salute you for being here
with that
uh with the weather that was out there
but a big day three bills
gold medal congressional gold medal
honoring our our
capitol police and others uh the
equality act any discrimination against
the lgbtq community
uh the citizen the american citizenship
act of
president um biden very important and
then
continuing our work on on covet
as we leave though i do want to uh say
once again
because i saw some of you on saturday
night
how proud we were and are of our
managers led by jamie raskin on how they
honored their oath and helped us honor
our oath to protect and defend
the constitution and they were doing so
at the same time as we were honoring our
values
meeting the needs of the american people
uh in the coveted
legislation dispelling i don't even why
any of you got this idea
that it was that our honoring our
constitutional oath
would come at the cost of our honoring
meeting the needs of the american people
we're so proud of them as we are proud
of our chairs for the work that they did
to take us forward now
thank you all very much be careful stay
safe thank you
thank you
is